paul goldschmidt could be an mvp this
year for the cardinals and so could
number 50. he has come up time and again
this year in 2020 well this would be if
i was handing out an award right now and
not to take away anything from what
goldie has done you look look at his
overall numbers they are very very good
but that's your mvp right there you're
right he has stepped up at every single
turn infield pretty much straight up for
akiyama left-handed batter
put in play just over wainwright
charging and wong tough play
and he makes it look easy one away
colton had to be really quick on this
transfer adam tries to get to it he
can't quite get there it's a nice
curveball really soft contact joey vada
will stand in bottle hitting in the
three hole tonight he's hitting 216 six
homers and 12 rbis runner on at first
base castellanos and vato swings hammers
it deep right field way back there and
it is gone way out of here to right
field a two-run home run for joey votto
he'll take that as opposed to a walk
it's a two-run blast to put the reds on
top early you can see the tilt of the
head in frustration by adam wainwright
as soon as the ball came off the bat and
votto knew it kiss that baby goodbye
styling after that one a little
watching it fly luis castillo record is
a bit deceiving earned his first win
last friday that was 4-2 in pittsburgh
on the 1-2 pitch
swing and a miss
good start for luis
i like that downward action you see it
as a fastball and the ball just
disappears and even if you make contact
with it at that point as the ball goes
down you're going to hit the top of the
ball and hit it right into the ground
here's paul the young
and that is hit fair
down into the left field corner miller
on his way to third pop warner will hold
him up and it's a double for paul to
young
last year de young his babbitt so the
batting average for balls in play was
259 this year 383 so he puts the ball in
play and it's doing some damage he has
driven in 16 of his 18 runs with runners
in scoring position
[Applause]
slowly hit right side that'll do the job
a race to the bag and save at first
carpenter beat it out
and the run scores and st louis gets on
the board
little check swing excuse me carpenter
takes it and that makes it 2-1
reds are going to challenge the verdict
is in he is out but the run will score
suarez bats now and he grounds one fair
down the third base line rolling into
the left field corner akiyama's home to
score votto around to third and into
second base
with an rbi double a eugenio suarez and
what he's doing with a lot of righties
or lefties is that first pitch curveball
thinking okay i can just roll this over
the plate nobody wants to hit a ball
that starts head high
well the reds have done their homework
that is 1-0 on brad miller he walked and
scored in the second inning
and he shoots the gap into left center
field goodwin is there on the run to
make the catch the fine play in left
center by brian goodwin picked up at the
deadline from the angels
he's got a power and speed combo that he
we haven't seen him unlock here yet mr
joey bottom two run homer in the first
inning walked in the third
3-2 pitch vato breaks his bat and hits a
little flare short right center coming
on in a hurry and a sliding catch by
lane thomas he made quite a divot
it's a shallow
crater in right center got his feet
caught under him but still able to make
the catch now it gives young jose garcia
a chance to
drive in a run
3-2 and he struck him out comes back to
get him garcia down on strikes the
inning is over the red strand two couple
of singles leave them both and we go to
the bottom of the sixth inning
nobody on two men are out three to one
reds leading ground ball headed for
short two hopper to de young he's in to
field it throws in time gets the out
reds are down in order in the seventh
time to stretch in st louis go for two
with a pair of ground outs to third jose
garcia gloves spins and throws in time
to get the out on yada year molina and
boy luis castillo is really sailing
along eight straight retired as he
retires the cardinals in order in the
seventh three to one reds lead the
redbird deal an out away from completing
pete innings it will be the fourth time
in his career thomas pops it high into
the air short center field out goes
galbas in comes goodwin it's goodwin
he's got it what an effort so far for
luis castillo the 3-1 lead has less than
100 pitches hitting for his first
complete game of his career
now the pitch swing gonna miss struck
him out on a change up down on strikes
colton wong six strikeouts for castillo
one gone to the ninth oh one pitch back
to castillo bobbles it recovers
in time it's the first complete game of
luis castillo's career